and specifically, it's
uniform over those strings that have binary dot
product equal to 0 with s.
Now that we know how the circuit
for Simon's algorithm works and specifically what
the probabilities are for the different measurement outcomes,
it remains to explain how this helps us to solve Simon's problem.
Summarizing what we just learned, if it's the case that the function f satisfies the promise in Simon's problem,
when the hidden string s
is the all-zero string, we obtain a completely random
string from the measurements,
where each end bit string
y is equally likely.
If on the other hand, the function f satisfies the promise for a different string s, one that's not equal
to the all-zero string,
then we get a random string y having binary dot product
equal to 0 with s, and among all of those strings,
each y is equally likely.
But we'll never get a string y having binary dot product
equal to 1 with s.
The question becomes, "Is this enough information
to determine s?" And the answer, as I've
already suggested, is yes,
provided that we run the
circuit enough times.
Specifically, let's suppose
that we run the circuit k times, where K is equal to n plus r,
where r is some number that's going to control the
likelihood that we recover s.
Just as an example, if
we choose r to be 10, we'll be successful with
probability greater than 99.9%,
so we don't need r to be all that large.
In general, the probability of failure is less than the probability
of flipping a fair coin r times and getting heads every single time.
So if 99.9% isn't good
enough, then take r to be 20, and the chance of failure is
less than one in a million,
or choose whatever r
makes you comfortable. You can't guarantee a correct solution, but you can make the
probability of error negligible
for all intents and purposes.
Here we are naming these
strings y1 through yk, where we're using superscripts to help us to name these strings,
just so that we can reserve subscripts to refer to the individual
bits of those strings.
So these aren't exponents
or anything like that, these are just the names that we're giving to these k strings.
Each one has length n because we got them
from running the circuit for Simon's algorithm.
So we can write down the
individual bits of these k strings like you see right here.
What we do now is to create a matrix m, where each entry of this matrix is a bit, and we get these bits from the strings
that we just measured, just like as shown right here.
So this matrix has k rows and n columns, and its entries are all binary values.
Now, we don't know what s is. That's what we're trying to find, but just imagine for a
moment that we did know s,
and we formed a column
vector from the bits of s, just like is shown right here.
If we were to multiply that vector by m and then take the result modulo-2, or another way of saying that
is that we replace addition
with the eXclusive OR, then we will necessarily
get the all-zero vector.
That's because each of the
entries in this resulting vector is none other than the
binary dot product of s
with one of the rows of m.
If S happens to be the all-zero string, we'll always get the zero vector from the binary dot product.
And if s is not the all-zero string, we'll get this from what we
know about the probabilities for the strings y1 through yk to appear.
In particular, the
binary dot product with s is always zero for all of these strings.
A simple way of saying that is that this vector
formed from the bits of s is always in the null
space of the matrix m,
assuming that we're doing all
of our arithmetic modulo-2, but of course, we don't know what s is,
we're trying to find s.
But what we can do is that we can compute the
null space of this matrix m, once again, modulo-2.
Specifically, we can do that using the technique of
Gaussian elimination, which is the procedure that's often taught
in introductory linear algebra courses.
It works perfectly well when we do all of our arithmetic modulo-2, and it can be done quite
efficiently with a computer.
And if we compute the null space of m, given the specific way that these k strings have
been randomly chosen,
we will be able to recover s with probability greater than
1 minus 2 to the negative r.
To be specific, what we will see with probability greater than
1 minus 2 to the negative r is that the null space
includes the all-zero vector,
as it always does for every matrix, as well as the vector corresponding to s, whether it's the all-zero vector or not.
And most importantly, no other vectors will
appear in the null space.
It's actually not too hard to prove this, although I won't go through it in detail.